Speaker 1: All right.
I have something extra special for you today.
Our friend and correspondent Luke Beesley
was in Latrobe, Pennsylvania for the Trump
rally.
He interviewed a dozen people.
And we are going to look at it right now.
Now, a few things that I want to say here
and this I'm not joking about this.
When we were not even playing everything for
you, there's some stuff Luke sent me that
seemed so obviously in the wrong category,
and I'll tell you the categories in a second
that it just felt like I just shouldn't even
use it, but as a general thing.
By definition, if you survey the MAGA movement,
they have delusional, incoherent beliefs that
in any other context we would say that's mental
illness.
And so you go and you interview people and
they all kind of seem mentally ill.
And it really raises a question for people
who are wanting to say, let's hear from this
movement.
There's tens of millions of these people.
We want to talk to them.
And then you talk to them and you go, Can
I even air this because they seem mentally
ill?
Am I is is my doing something wrong by showing
that this is what they say?
There's obviously cult beliefs and people
that are just sucked into a cult and then
there's ignorance and there's mental illness
and it's a Venn diagram.
I don't know exactly where each of these people
are, but it's something we really think about.
And I cut out some stuff.
So let's just start, Luke first talking to
a couple of women.
One of them says Trump is currently the president.
The other woman in the middle kind of doesn't
seem to buy it.
And Luke does a really good job here.
Let's let's start.
And by the way, it was really windy.
So at certain points there's just like wind
noise.
Luke did the best he could.
No.
Speaker 4: I'm not.
Even though he's president.
Speaker 6: Really?
Speaker 1: That's the Tucker Carlson psychotic
laugh.
Speaker 4: I do question that.
Speaker 6: Who do you think is the real friends?
Speaker 4: Donald Trump.
I think he'll be back any day now under military.
Speaker 1: So she says Trump's the current
president.
He will be back any day under military.
Now, look at the look on the other woman's
face.
She's starting to say.
I may be nuts, but I'm not as nuts as this
lady.
Speaker 6: Oh, okay.
But this is the thing with that I got to filter
out.
He is attacking Biden's performance as president.
But who is the real president?
Yep.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Luke, why is that so hard for you to understand?
Yes.
Speaker 6: So he's to blame for inflation?
Speaker 4: No, no, I believe that.
Well, no, he not.
Oh, yeah.
I believe there's a show going on.
I'm believing he's letting this happen to
show people what what this world would be
without actually God's letting this out.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
Do you guys understand what's going on?
Trump is the real president under military.
Oh, so if the president is responsible for
inflation, inflation must be Trump's fault,
not Biden's.
No, Trump.
Actually, God, God and Trump are allowing
Biden to pretend to be president to show you
if he were the real president, he would make
inflation go up, which he did, even though
he's not the real president.
Why won't people just accept this?
Looks like all skeptical, as if this doesn't
make sense.
Speaker 4: He totally has command.
Biden is completely.
Hello.
Have you talked?
Have you heard him talk?
Who votes for someone like that?
This ain't real.
This is not a real thing.
Okay, well, I'm just going to make this prediction.
Do I believe it?
Donald Trump is going to take back over every
executive order that Biden put in.
I'll be going very second.
He takes back over.
Yeah.
Speaker 6: And you and you were saying I heard
the beginning of that is that the military
was going to do that?
Yes, the.
Speaker 1: Military is going to do it.
So Trump's going to do it.
The military is going to do it.
Everybody's doing it.
Is that a cult member?
Is that an ignorant person?
Is that a mentally ill person?
I'm not sure.
Here is a woman who makes what I call an indivisible,
feasible argument.
And that's these are particular types of arguments
that make it really tough to talk to these
folks.
Speaker 4: That is our right as an American
that our votes count and it did not occur
in the 2020 election.
Speaker 6: I press or ask all about that specifically.
So with all the evidence that I am, you know,
hearing a lot from people here that they believe
that, in fact, they've seen evidence.
Why?
For someone who's trying to strictly go to
the things that they know can be verified
has not been shown up in any of the court
cases that have been done, plus any of the
audits that have been done among the many.
Speaker 4: There's corruption.
I not that they weren't audits that, you know,
counted the votes.
I mean, they were scoring an audit.
Speaker 1: Understand what's going on this.
These are indivisible arguments.
You can't defeat them.
Okay.
The example I gave on the stream is as follows
Someone comes to me with tears in their eyes
and then say, David, sir, there there's a
tiger in the room with you right now.
Be careful, because in the studio, right in
this studio with me right now, there's a tiger.
And I go, oh, okay.
I don't see a tiger.
They say, Tiger's invisible.
Okay.
Invisible tiger is unusual, but fine, let's
do this.
Let's put baby powder down on the floor so
that because the invisible tiger still has
mass and volume, as the tiger moves around,
it will disturb the baby powder on the floor
and they'll go, now it's weightless.
It's a weightless, invisible tiger.
And then I say, Well, at some point this tiger
is going to need to eat.
Let's put food down on the floor.
So even if we won't see the tiger because
it's invisible, and even if the tiger also
doesn't have any weight or mass so it won't
move around, the baby powder when it eats,
will see the food being eaten like, oh, no,
it's a special tiger that doesn't need to
eat.
That's what these women are doing.
They will always say, No, no, but the audits
weren't done correctly and the judges were
corrupt on.
Speaker 4: I mean, it was an audit in a sense,
but it wasn't an audit to actually.
Right.
Speaker 1: It wasn't an audit that was going
to put Trump in the White House is what she
means.
Speaker 4: The votes and the errors that that
went on during the election, I mean, they're.
Speaker 6: All alone in the world.
The reason why I have a hard time believing
some of these claims is because, like, the
point would maybe make more sense if a lot
of the judges that.
These cases were put in front of were appointed
by Trump.
And so I guess is it given them?
Speaker 4: Yeah.
You're saying yes.
Well, a lot of people that were appointed
by Trump really, I mean, backstabbed them.
Speaker 1: Yeah, exactly.
So it does affect they became corrupt after
Trump selected them.
Here's a guy who just straight up doesn't
believe the election results.
Speaker 6: And we're seeing kind of a phenomenon
going into this.
Midterms is very different than others where
a number of GOP candidates have indicated
kind of you've seen the ads like are you going
to concede if you lose?
And it's like now if we lose five because
the Democrats stole it, is that a mindset
that you guys share?
You want to answer anything but.
Speaker 4: Oh, I definitely think it was stolen.
Yeah.
I always think that they could tell.
Speaker 1: I always think that.
Speaker 4: That's a lie and I'll never believe
that it was.
Speaker 6: Megyn interesting.
That is something that a lot of times I'll
say in conversations like What would I have
to show you or pose to you that would change
your mind on that particular issue?
Speaker 4: I don't think there is anything
to show.
I remember looking back when I was showing
all these people at the election, places where
the votes were and everybody's running around
covering up windows and stuff.
Nobody wanted them to see em.
Speaker 1: I mean, who even knows what she's
talking about?
People covered windows, so therefore Trump
actually won.
Then he interviews a guy who seems dead set
on repeating multiple times that he does martial
arts.
Martial arts clearly very important to this
guy who also, by the way, is wearing an ultra
maga shirt.
Speaker 2: This is rich shade, Christian patriot,
mixed martial arts expert and the world's
most handsome man.
Speaker 6: What are your feelings since they
kind of began the news right now about the
investigation going on into him based on the
documents he had?
Speaker 2: It's nonsense.
I think the Justice Department right now is
is totally corrupt at the top.
I actually know some I train in mixed martial
arts.
We know judo getting close in design, jujitsu.
I know a lot of people in law enforcement.
I don't think that middle level people in
the FBI are crook, crooked.
But the upper level, we've never had anybody
weaponize the Justice Department against their
opponents like Joe Biden's doing.
Right.
Speaker 1: So what's interesting about this
one is that this is verbatim stuff that Trump
says verbatim.
They've weaponized the Justice Department,
it's never been done, etc., etc..
Not particularly interesting other than that.
But understand, the cult followers are paying
very close attention.
They're getting the exact terminology from
Trump.
Here's another guy who, you know, again, I
don't really know what he's talking about,
totally incoherent.
Speaker 2: We lose the one where any of us
were born or our parents or ancestors were
born, or was it the Native Americans in the
beginning or the white people, the original
occupants?
Speaker 1: The reason you hear Trump speaking
in the background, by the way, is half the
crowd was leaving while Trump was speaking.
So there were plenty of people to talk to
while the rally was going on.
Speaker 2: MAGA and now they got pushed out
by now.
I'm not saying I love hip hop culture.
Hip hop is like embedded in me.
Speaker 1: Embedded.
I like that.
That's a nice portmanteau of embedded and
bred into me.
It's been embedded into me.
Maybe the guy's just hungry.
Speaker 2: During a black soul, white body.
Not sure, but I still have my soul.
And the soul of America is, like, slow disappearing.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So he had opinions about things.
Here is a guy who believes that the Vatican
is actually controlling everything.
This one's really weird.
Speaker 6: What do you want to hear from Donald
Trump tonight?
Speaker 2: Make America Great again.
Speaker 6: And what has made it not great?
Speaker 2: What is made in our graves?
What's going on right now?
Open borders, high inflation, everything that's
going on right now just diametrically opposed.
The economy to tax, diametrically opposed.
Speaker 1: Again, they just make up words.
They're totally confident, make them up totally
confident.
Speaker 2: It's diametrically is 86,000 IRS
agents.
I mean, we have all night I mean, the moon
set tomorrow.
Speaker 6: So like you said, there's so many
issues.
Let's zero in on one inflation.
Are you saying you blame Joe Biden for inflation?
Speaker 2: Well, when you you stop fossil
fuels and the countries run out of diesel
in 17 days and no trucks, no boats, no plague,
nothing is going to be moving.
Yeah, you might want to open up fossil fuels.
I think this has come.
I think it's coming from the Vatican.
Speaker 1: The Vatican's meeting, he hesitates
before dropping this bomb.
Speaker 2: They were world leaders.
And at Mount Sinai, Joe Biden is getting his
marching orders from the Jesuit oath.
If you open up to Jesuit, this might be look
crazy to these people.
I don't really care.
Good.
Go to Jesuit oath that when Joe Biden was
elected president, he opened up on a with
a Jesuit priest on a Jesuit Bible.
We've had two Roman Catholic presidents in
this country and Joe Biden has taken order.
Just read a Jesuit oath that explains so much
of it.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So that's that's pretty bonkers stuff.
Here is one guy who just was furious and started
swearing, wearing an in a huge, huge hat.
Speaker 6: Tell me about what you saw, what
you liked.
Speaker 2: Like everything.
Everything?
Yep.
And I want to say something, but I can't say
it.
Speaker 6: But whatever the way.
Speaker 2: Because they're scumbags.
What are they doing to help this country?
You're young.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
The act is lowering prescription drug costs
be a change.
All right.
Why is issue that in your mind?
Speaker 1: Just be all right anyway.
I won't stick with the guys just swearing
so much.
We have to keep bleeping.
And then here's the last guy this is.
Then we got to the Cunanan guy.
Oh.
Speaker 5: I'm pretty far down the rabbit
hole, so I don't know what I think right now.
Speaker 6: So let me describe that for me.
Speaker 5: Oh, it's just the whole everything
that's going on in the world and things going
on in the world.
I mean, it's it's a lot of so-called conspiracy
theories, you know.
Speaker 6: Just for the heck of it, for the
game.
What would you say your most wild conspiracy
theory would be?
Speaker 1: And Luke's instincts impeccable.
They're to go right in for the most bonkers
thing.
Speaker 5: I guess there's really not a wildest
one.
They're all conspiracy theories until they
are one proven true or the masses believe
them.
So, I mean, there's there's been some wild
ones over there over the time, you know, with
all the child sex trafficking and Donald Trump
being the first president to fight against
that.
It's not a conspiracy theory.
Speaker 1: It's the truth.
Speaker 6: So child sex trafficking, huge
problem.
I totally agree with you that should be addressed.
It's the connection, I guess, to like it's
the Democratic Party who's doing this and
Biden's in the back.
Speaker 5: Really, it's good versus evil.
It's it's not Republican versus Democrat.
There are a lot of evil people in the world,
period, whether they're Democrat or Republican
rhinos.
And they're bad for the party and bad for
the country.
Speaker 6: And that's Trump's relationship
with I've seen before he died by the at all.
Speaker 5: I don't think so.
Speaker 1: Uh, that's that's gotta.
There's pedophiles everywhere.
It's Republicans.
It's Democrats.
It's all of them.
We got to root them out.
Oh, yeah.
Trump was friends with Epstein.
That a problem?
No, no, no, no.
And watch what the guy says he comes up with.
Trump was probably undercover.
Speaker 5: No, I don't think so.
It doesn't bother me because I if anything,
I would think that would be like a, you know,
an inside, you know, I mean, like he was on
the inside getting into.
There you go.
Same thing he did with the the mafia people
that saved his hotels.
And they were getting information back years
ago in Trump hotels he was playing.
Speaker 6: I've seen.
I think so.
It's interesting.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: This gets even crazier and we'll
have the full clip online.
But that one was really wild so really, really
good job by Luke Beasley you can find his
YouTube channel make sure to subscribe Go
to David Pakman dot com slash Luke and you
will
find
it all.